un año nuevo que arranca con esperanzas
de paz para Colombia el presidente
Gustavo Petro anunció en su cuenta de
Twitter el cc bilateral al fuego con
cinco grupos armados ilegales que durará
por lo menos seis meses hemos acordado
un cese bilateral con el eln la segunda
marquetalia el Estado Mayor central las
agc y las autodefensas de la Sierra
Nevada desde el primero de enero hasta
el 30 de junio de 2023 prorrogable según
los avances en las negociaciones la paz
total será una realidad
este anuncio es consecuente con una de
las principales promesas que el
presidente Petro hizo en campaña de
hacer lo que llamó la paz total con
todos los grupos armados una política
dentro de la cual reinició la
negociación con la guerrilla del eln en
noviembre de 2022 según el gobierno
colombiano el principal objetivo de este
histórico cese bilateral es suspender la
afectación humanitaria de la población
especialmente comunidades negras e
indígenas que habitan territorios
golpeados por el conflicto armado
interno sin embargo La tregua con estos
grupos armados ilegales es más compleja
que la alcanzada en el proceso de paz
con una extinta guerrilla de las Farc en
2016 organización en la que existía una
verticalidad en las decisiones y la
forma de operar es importante involucrar
a estos grupos porque Colombia en los
últimos cuatro o cinco años ha venido
transitando por una multiplicidad de
conflictos armados dejamos atrás los
conflictos de la guerrilla con el estado
y de paramilitares con el estado y ahora
Estamos en una multiplicidad de
conflictos en los cuales estos grupos se
enfrentan entre sí y con el eln Además
del del estado con el eln en estos
conflictos Colombia registró 92 masacres
en 2022 y 37 firmantes de paz fueron
asesinados